[Música]
economía en directo américa de france24
daniela qué bueno tenerla en nuestro
estudio para volver a hablar de economía
y empezamos en asia sir lanka logró un
preacuerdo de rescate económico con el
fondo monetario internacional y porque
estaba buscando este rescate pues porque
este país asiático de poco más de 20
millones de habitantes está en medio de
una crisis económica sin precedentes
aunque los suministros de gas para
cocinar que estaban bastante bajos de se
restauraron gracias al apoyo del banco
mundial todavía hay escasez de
combustible también de medicamentos
esenciales de algunos alimentos y sobre
todo de divisas tiene una deuda de más
de 50 mil millones de dólares y acudió
entonces al fondo monetario
internacional para que lo ayude a salir
de esta situación después de meses de
negociaciones este jueves se anunció
finalmente que llegaron a un acuerdo
preliminar sobre un programa de rescate
de 2900 millones de dólares por cuatro
años pero con la condición de que haga
una serie de reformas que siempre
resultan impopulares y que incluyen en
la mayoría de los casos reducción de
gastos aumento de impuestos y
eliminación de subsidios entre otros
escuchamos que dijo el fondo monetario
el objetivo de este programa económico
respaldado por el fondo es restablecer
la estabilidad macroeconómica y la
sostenibilidad de la deuda al tiempo que
protege a los vulnerables
y
salvaguardar la estabilidad financiera e
intensifica las reformas estructurales
para abordar la vulnerabilidad de
corrupción y desbloquear el potencial de
crecimiento del tri lanka en el futuro
daniela y lamentablemente las personas
que están en alemania sobre todo y que
van a viajar mañana pues van a tener
dificultades para hacerlo porque porque
lufthansa va a cancelar mayoría de sus
vuelos para el día de mañana viernes
exactamente roble estamos hablando de
800 vuelos y de 130 mil pasajeros
afectados esa es la estimación de los
efectos que tendrá una huelga de un día
de los pilotos de la aerolínea alemana
lufthansa el paro que comienza a la
medianoche de este jueves impactará
principalmente a los aeropuertos de
fráncfort
el sindicato exige un aumento salarial
del 5 5% para sus más de 5000 pilotos y
también una compensación adicional por
inflación y la aerolínea ofrece 900
euros más en salario básico por mes en
12 etapas durante un plazo de 18 meses
sin embargo pues el sindicato lo
considera insuficiente
danny y ahora es francia la que le dice
los rusos ya yo no quiero más uvas sí
señor pues avanza el segundo día de
suspensión de envíos por el gasoducto
nord stream hacia alemania este jueves
el gigante energético estatal ruso
gazprom adicionalmente para todas las
entregas a la empresa de gas francesa
engine alegando que tiene facturas
impagas francia depende mucho menos del
gas ruso que sus vecinos europeos antes
de la guerra obtenía alrededor del 17
por ciento de sus suministros desde
rusia ahora es un 4% sin embargo los
problemas de mantenimiento en la antigua
flota de reactores nucleares del país
significan que aún se avecina una
posible crisis energética durante el
invierno que se aproxima la ministra la
primera ministra elizabeth board
y advirtió que en el peor de los casos
los hogares franceses podrían verse
afectados por apagones continuos de dos
horas este invierno pero dijo que no
habría problemas si se llegara a lograr
un ahorro del 10 por ciento en el
consumo energético danny vamos ahora con
los indicadores económicos para los
principales índices de estados unidos
abrieron a la baja y han sufrido cuatro
días consecutivos de caídas desde que el
presidente de la reserva federal dijo el
viernes pasado que el banco central
probablemente va a necesitar mantener
las tasas de interés lo suficientemente
altas como para desacelerar la economía
eso con el fin de recuperarse de una
inflación máxima en cuatro décadas si
nos vamos para europa la tendencia
bajista está siendo alimentada por la
posibilidad de que el banco central
europeo eleve su tasa en un récord de 75
puntos básicos la próxima semana luego
de ver también que la inflación de la
eurozona salto a un nuevo récord en
agosto las acciones asiáticas también
cayeron con fuerza movidas por un
frenazo en la manufactura china en
agosto tal y como siempre gracias por
toda la información económica volamos
directo sin escalas hasta parís para
hablar de toda la actualidad francesa